puis
[Musique]
à
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro 17 8 culture aujourd'hui
nous sommes au domaine de dampierre en
yvelines classé monument historique
depuis février dernier la première phase
de restauration s'achève mais avant cela
voici le sommaire première phase de
travaux terminés du château de dampierre
en yvelines le filet de chantier a été
partiellement retiré les visiteurs
pourront découvrir dès l'été la nouvelle
robe du château et profitez de nombreux
événements à venir au domaine silva et
sacra et la forêt des solitaires c'est
le nom de la nouvelle exposition du
musée de port royal des champs à magny
les hameaux visible jusqu'au 4 juillet
elle retrace les déserts rêver du xviie
siècle et enfin la nouvelle saison
culturelle 2022 2023 du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est dévoilé le
directeur de l'établissement nous
présente trois temps forts de la saison
prochaine
[Musique]
je me trouve dans le domaine de
dampierre en yvelines depuis le 26 mars
il a rouvert ses jardins au public
balades en attelage barque sur l'étang
ou encore aux voiturettes électriques de
nombreux moyens sont mises à disposition
pour découvrir le site de 90 hectares
pascal terreur bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur général du domaine de dante
hier en yvelines en février le domaine a
été classé monument historique
c'est une fierté un aboutissement quel
est votre sentiment alors c'était
vraiment une fierté évidemment déjà de
faire accepter que enfin de comprendre
que le domaine n'était pas protégé au
titre des monuments historiques ni même
le château c'était pour moi quelque
chose qui était incompréhensible le
classement c'est une notoriété et quand
cette demande d'ami même pas un an à
être traités c'est vraiment exceptionnel
parce que c'est donc hier et bien le 3
février 2000 22 cantons a reçu ce
courrier ah là là c'était la joie
puisque c'était vraiment un domaine dans
sa totalité 400 hectares y compris le
mur classé au titre des monuments
historiques on reconnaît la valeur
patrimoniale de dampierre dans
l'histoire de france est dans l'intérêt
général de la france on l'a dit le
domaine vient de rouvrir en mars dernier
qu'est ce que les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir
les découvre évidemment le jardin
puisque le château est en chantier donc
c'est un jardin de 90 hectares où on a
beaucoup axé nos activités sur
l'histoire des jardins l'histoire de
l'environnement la biodiversité on a un
chemin des libellules qui permet de
faire le tour du desjardins en
profondeur ça c'est la nouveauté il ya
aussi un autre parcours un parcours
digne des chimères qu'on a amélioré par
rapport à l'année dernière et là on
vient même s'inscrire avec la visite
accompagnée d'un guide un guide costumé
qui vous fait une immersion au xviiie
siècle et vous promener dans les
bosquets dans les jardins et puis on a
toujours le grand succès c'est nos
tables de pique nique les gens viennent
s'installer viennent avec des draps de
bain se faire bronzer sur les pelouses
et ça les gens adorent avec les aires de
jeu naturel qu'on a complété évidemment
c'est quelque chose c'est une journée
nature dans un patrimoine de dampierre
que nous proposons au public tout au
long de la saison vous avez une
programmation assez riche quels sont les
temps forts
ces prochains mois d'autres temps forts
parmi ceux prochains voiliers les belles
de dampierre c'est une nouveauté on veut
rendre à situer institutionnalisée une
date en mois de juin on accueille les
véhicules anciens les véhicules rétro
alors cette année c'est avec
l'association de versailles la vava et
où on a quelques voitures mais surtout
monsieur mulliez il a découvert dans une
collection d'attelage qui l'avait qu'il
y avait un véhicule de 1900 motorisés et
donc du coup on est en train de la
réparer pour la remettre en route une
voiture et américaines
très peu d'exemplaires qui existent au
monde et dans sa collection on a
découvert qu'il y avait ce véhicule
évidemment les plaisirs de dampierre les
blessures de dampierre qui est
maintenant le rassemblement qu'on fait
on plonge au coeur du xviiie siècle
c'est la venue de louis 15 élus 15 sera
là on a recomposé la scénographie
l'année dernière et puis on fait un
marché certes il ya un marché non pas de
producteur met à marcher comme au xviiie
siècle où il ya des chalands qui ceux
qui vont se promener avec tous les
colporteurs et autres et donc il ya la
vie de cour d'un côté et puis le marché
de l'autre et avec des animations
offertes pour les enfants et puis après
les journées du patrimoine évidemment et
puis à
plus tard alors là c'est au mois
d'octobre une date à retenir
impérativement pour la nuit des châteaux
grosse surprise sur le château vous
donc emballé le la première phase du
chantier de restauration du domaine
comprend le clos et couvert du corps
central du château vient de s'achever à
une opération qui aura duré deux ans
concrètement quels ont été les travaux
réalisés alors il a fallu tout reprendre
les couvertures et des fuyards
évidemment les couvertures filia de
sabine la charpente dessous ça abîme la
maçonnerie vous imaginez tout le en
cascade tout ce qu'il ya comme un
problème donc il a fallu reprendre tous
et reprendre les couvertures tu te sens
milk ardoise qui ont été posées 200000
cloud cuivre des mètres cubes de bois
remplacer tous les enduits ont été
restaurés et puis les menuiseries des
menuiseries pour assurer le clos et le
couvert c'est le clos et pour piquer de
fuites d'air à l'intérieur et bien
toutes les menuiseries ont été restaurés
la fin du chantier marque également la
dépose du filet alors on peut le voir
derrière nous 1 l'occasion de dévoiler
la nouvelle rue chalon la nouvelle robe
du château et se dévoile tout doucement
alors c'est pas la fin du chantier c'est
la fin d'une étape dans le chantier
puisque à partir du 6 juin jusqu'au 6
juin tout doucement les filets vont
tomber on a fait aujourd'hui 7 ce
démontage et à partir du 6 juin les
parapluies en taule va être enlevé les
échafaudages ont tombé à partir du 14
juillet la nouvelle robe apparaîtra sous
les ardoises d'huile des deux tourelles
de la façade nord une boîte
commémorative sera posée et le
propriétaire du château franky mulliez
nous en parle
c'est pour redorer ce qu'ils ont fait le
boulot les ceux qui ont de l'or dans les
mains comme j'ai dit ils t'ont donné
chacun de leur savoir faire et donc qui
mérite d'être honoré donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya tous les noms dans leur chemin
vous l'avez dit normalement la fin des
travaux donc aura lieu fin juillet est
ce que d'autres devraient suivre dans la
foulée on ne va pas s'arrêter monsieur
mulliez a défini une grande phase de
travaux avec son architecte en chef
toute la grande perspective du château
qui passe depuis la demi lune qui est de
l'autre côté de la route que tout le
monde connaît puisque tout ne vient
s'installer librement face au château le
château va être va continuer par la
restauration de
deals 15 août pardon des deux pavillons
qui se trouve au bord de route avec la
grille avec les murs de part et d'autre
qui vont être restaurés ça à partir du
15 août à partir de début septembre
c'est la restauration d'un hectare et
demi de cours les réseaux de sous les
pavés et après on pourra marcher sans se
tordre riches puissants sans peiner pour
les fauteuils roulants et les poussettes
et puis ensuite eh bien on va commencer
les travaux de restauration intérieure
du château pour présenter la collection
d'oeuvres d'art de monsieur mulliez et
la restitution des jardins de l'autre
côté du château merci beaucoup m kalt
heyvaert d'avoir été le travail était
merci
au musée de port royal des champs à
magny les hameaux une nouvelle
exposition est visible jusqu'au 4
juillet son nom silva et sacra et la
forêt des solitaires en voyage à travers
les déserts rêver du xviie siècle
[Musique]
sorte d'emblème religieux la forêt
l'endroit au xviie siècle où les
personnes y viennent chercher la
quiétude la solitude l'introspection ou
encore un dialogue avec dieu c'est aussi
le symbole du désert
quel désert le désert de l'egypte dans
lequel au 4e siècle se serait retirée
elle les premiers grands airs mythes de
l'histoire de l'église occidentale
on n'a pas de désert à se mettre sous la
main et depuis le 14e ou 15e siècle en
europe c'est la forêt qui représente ce
désert
silva et sacra et la forêt des
solitaires est visible jusqu'au 4
juillet au bizet de port royal des
champs une cinquantaine de dessins sont
répartis dans deux salles ils ont été
prêtés par l'albertina devienne la
fondation custodia ou le musée du louvre
pour pouvoir montrer ce désert des
ermites les artistes ont imaginé
plusieurs formes de représentation de la
forêt
ce sont souvent de très grands paysages
soient traités comme les italiens savent
le traité depuis la renaissance soient
traités comme les artistes du nord de
grandes forêts profondes dans lequel on
voit deux petites représentations de
personnages seules vivant dans des
petites cabanes lisent en écrivant ou
travaillant en 1639 antoine lemaitre
grand avocat abandonne son métier décide
de vivre comme un arbitres il devient le
premier solitaire de port royal des
champs ce dessin de philippe de
champaigne est réalisée en 1654 pour la
communauté des chartreux c'est un projet
pour un grand tableau l'hôtel qui
représente saint bruno et les 12
premiers compagnons de saint bruno dans
le massif de la grande chartreuse dans
ce dessein
philippe de champaigne choisi d'utiliser
les méthodes mises au point par martin
devos pour représenter les moines au des
heures dans le cadre de l'exposition une
programmation musicale sera proposée
dimanche 12 juin et dimanche 19 juin à
17 heures à la grange à blé au musée de
port royal des champs
dans les yvelines des rendez vous sont à
prévoir également dans vos agendas avec
la fête de l'estampé à saint quentin en
yvelines qui revient pour une 10e
édition jeudi 26 mai de 14h à 18h et les
samedis et dimanches 11 et 12 juin et 18
et 19 juin l'exposition de livres
d'artistes et des estampes impression
végétal aura lieu à elancourt une
manifestation consacrée à la gravure
lithographie et la sérigraphie jaune
rime avec jardin pour le musée
départemental maurice denis situé à
saint germain en laye durant tout le
mois et pendant chaque week end des
ateliers des visites des concerts ou
encore du live painting seront proposées
aux visiteurs
[Musique]
la saison culturelle 2022 2023 du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
sera entièrement dévoilée en septembre
prochain mais en avant-première lionel
massé talent le directeur nous présente
quelques temps forts de la saison
prochaine
[Musique]
ces gros patine bien ça a été conçu et
joué par olivier martin salvan et pierre
guillois qui se sont amusés à cons sur
cette folie qui est digne des monty
python on est d'assurer sur une sorte de
road trip
d'épopée qui nous amène de l'islande à
au sud de l'espagne
[Musique]
mine de rien adaptation du chef-d'oeuvre
de la mgm qui avait été sept film
musical qui avait été réalisé en 1952 là
c'est une adaptation pour la scène par
un ensemble qui s'appelle ars lyrique à
une adaptation extrêmement fidèle au
film drôle le film raconte l'histoire du
passage du muet du film muet du cinéma
muet au cinéma parlant sur scène c'est
ou en phase de recueil ses 50 musiciens
chanteurs danseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
youssoupha dans une forme très
particulière donc le rappeur youssoupha
qui avait été révélée au public par
l'album noir désir je crois que c'était
il ya dix ou 10 ou 11 ans et qui va
revisiter ses 20 ans de carrière et ses
vingt ans de rap avec un spectacle qui
s'appelle youssoupha gospel expérience
sur scène un choeur gospel et 24
musiciens classiques
[Musique]
le festival escales d'ailleurs est de
retour à plaisir samedi 11 juin de 15
heures à 18 heures dans le parc du
château au programme musique spectacles
arts de la rue ou encore jeux le maire
adjoint délégué à la culture nous en
parle l'escale d'ailleurs qui que
festival des arts du monde où on va
aussi découvrir un petit peu de richesse
culturelle musicale ou au niveau du pôle
danse dans la cour des communs de vos
oreilles comme d'habitude des spectacles
musicaux cette fois ci avec des artistes
professionnels
on aura quatre concerts qui vont
s'enchaîner
jusqu'à 22h à peu près et puis de
l'autre côté du château il y aura
toujours des démonstrations circassienne
des déambulations de marionnettes
etc la fin de 7,8 culture merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine dans un autre lieu culturel
yvelinois bob tahri sur télé 518
[Musique]